yes
when looking at a cast of characters in
an anime some people just make a bigger
impression you often have the loud
character or the big guy you know those
guys that you typically would expect to
explode in a flurry to save their
friends however today's list is not
about those people to be honest I'm a
bit more partial to the karma characters
on the side of the spectrum after all
they make good candidates for today's
list which is going to be about some top
moments of a calm character just
snapping and raising hell to shake
things up a little bit though I'm not
limiting this list to the full
introverted characters I also want to
feature some extra virgin or outgoing
protagonists who may not be as loud as
they mentioned counterparts consider
this a spiritual successor to the top
rage moments or a retake if you're new
to the channel and haven't seen those
videos yet if you fall in the latter
especially I'd like to ask you a little
favor and to hit that subscribe button
if you haven't done so already now let's
begin
Levi's no Aaron that's for sure and I
don't even think that I'll be able to
remain composed considering all the
things he's been through in the whole of
Attack on Titan how however when he gets
into the zone of raging Fury there's
little anyone can do to stop Levi he's
got several of these moments but I'd
like to feature the OVA moment because
it's one of those early instances and
it's something that fewer people might
know about after all I'm sure everyone
and their children already know about
him going ham on the Beast Titan
seriously though this moment from the
OVA is more emotional than anything you
can just feel the power in the scene and
it further exemplifies the things the
Levi had to endure to mold him into the
strongest soldier that we know and love
losing friends is never easy but hearing
Levi scream and the pure emotion being
channeled in this scene gave me the
chills
yo Loy
Al
sauce
talking about Levi really reminded me of
Roy Mustang it must be the similarities
in backgrounds but I think they had
comparable rage moments where they just
go to town against their enemies however
I'd say that amongst the many scenes of
Mustang kicking homunculus ass the
execution of Envy is by far the angriest
he's ever been poor Envy didn't even get
to finish his gloating before Mustang
appears and incinerates him people call
this a fight but as I've said in the
numerous times I've talked about this
before it's not one it's truly no
contest really and we see that even a
homunculus's power is useless in the
face of repeated unadulterated violence
from an angry Mustang yeah you could
argue that in some way Mustang C may not
be as emotional as Levi's but in terms
of the distraction that happened I dared
to say that this one's more impressive
what Emily
okay how about we move to main
characters now then gone comes to mind
you all know what I'm talking about who
could forget this iconic moment when
gone fights Beto and Taps into his inner
Abyss showing the way past the friendly
and outgoing facade of God the lies a
darkness that he kept hidden for so long
it's truly a horrific yet cathartic
moment to see God finally access this
side of him and it's pretty cool because
unlike Levi or Mustang's moments you can
still see an unsettling calmness in gone
scene despite him falling completely
into nihilism there's a sense of
controlled frenzy that's the best way to
describe it and because of that the
moments found its way into many people's
top Hunter Hunter moments
oh
my God
before we move on to the next moment I'd
like to take time to thank our sponsors
for today's video expressvpn expressvpn
is the number one VPN service that
allows you to access the internet like
never before that includes being able to
watch all of those shows legally even if
you're not in the supported region
because we all know that region locks
can be such a pain yes even in other
countries with tighter measures on
internet expressvpn has been my number
one partner and friend one of the things
preventing me from having one of those
aforementioned rage moments of my own
out of frustration I've used expressvpn
to re-watch attack on Titan recently and
let me just say that it boasts one of
the most simplest interfaces that I've
ever seen for a VPN just turn on this
bad boy and select the United States
server connect and enjoy some Titan
slaying goodness I also want to add the
expressvpn proudly presents top tier
protection for your data this way you
can browse the internet without worry
despite the growing worries on cyber
security these days and I would love you
to join the fun so don't forget to click
on the link in the description box or go
to expressvpn.com on slash Vinnie tube
to get started on a new safer internet
life for you now let's head back to the
video
Jiu Jitsu Kaizen storied Runners come to
an end but not before it gave us an
amazing Arc to cap things off what I
like about Jiu Jitsu Kaizen is that
throughout its run it got the chance to
show us some key moments from the main
characters everyone knows Gojo in his
moments but it really feels like one got
left behind as Jiu Jitsu Kaizen wrapped
up a couple of months ago megumi's
moment came into episode 23 when he
finally leaves his comfort zone in the
battle against the curse pushing himself
past his limits with his all-new domain
expansion kimira Shadow guarded and I'm
not sure about you but I feel like it's
a surreal sight to see megumi put off
such a dark and ominous looking ability
while bleeding with that crazed face on
everything from visuals to the voice
acting came together to make this a
scene to remember it came late in the
show's run but Jiu Jitsu Kaizen really
gave us a finale to remember for its
first season
foreign
hurt when I first saw it doraro seemed
to be a standard fantasy demon hunting
series with a Nifty premise but I think
the one moment which sets it apart from
the lock came pretty early on I'm
talking about episode 6 when we get to
see the full Glory of a raging
hiyakimaru who just tears through
everyone in his sight it's a level of
violence and anger that I didn't think
I'd find in the show at first but
yakimaru makes a whole show out of the
bloodbath that happens in that episode
remembering the scene there really
reminds me of the Levi moment that I
talked about but there's something just
so much more unsettling with how doraro
did it maybe because the violence was
done not against Monsters or demons but
people or maybe because of how much more
graphic it was anyway this is the very
scene that showed everyone that despite
his quiet and reserved nature kyakimaru
is something you wouldn't want to trifle
with
yes
in a call back to gone's moment we have
another protagonist embracing The
Emptiness within its mob with his
question mark percentage form
among the whole gallery of mobs forms
that tie to his emotions lies the Deep
depths of the question mark form an
enormous power that represents the
strength that he repressed in order to
appear normal this is by far the most
terrifying form of mob no questions
asked from the white and eyes the wildly
flaring hair to the evil looking Aura
now imagine if you were some unfortunate
slob like daruki if seeing that format
of someone you've just been beating up
moments ago doesn't give you the creeps
I don't know what will the look on
taruki's face after seeing the frankly
terrifying mob face says it all this new
form of mob literally beats the clothes
and hair out of the kokiteru although I
won't say that he didn't deserve it in
each of its subsequent appearances this
forms unloaded unadulterated destruction
on all that dared to pose it and you'll
quickly understand why the calm and
unimposing MOB would prefer attacking
this form away for good is something
that you should all look out for if
you're someone getting into mob psycho
foreign
ER to end the list with the show with
the greatest fondness for flipping the
switch so to speak in Tom is probably
the poster child of anime that can shift
from comedic and Goofy to straight up
epic action and drama no one embodies
that trade better than gintoki himself
for all the goofiness and relative child
that Kentucky has he can turn into an
Unstoppable engine of Destruction when
the right buttons are pushed as you see
in various instances in the series story
run for me my favorite amongst those
would have to be his fight versus
girocho the Ambiance is perfect the rain
The Perfect soundtrack and the
sequencing of events and fight
choreography make this a standout moment
to show your friends if you can find the
fight in high quality of course this is
one of the most passionate scenes in the
series that I can think of off the top
of my head seriously just watch the clip
and be amazed then ask yourself this is
gintoki on another note an interesting
thing about this moment is that it's the
only moment on the list that doesn't
result in a victory for the angry man
kintoki so consumed with rage that he
never got to fight properly and
reasonably especially against a monster
like jirojo kintama's not like one of
those anime we're getting angry or
fighting for those dear to you all
automatically wins you the fight you
know
as I close the list I'm always on the
lookout for scenes like the ones I just
mentioned so I'd love to hear your
suggestions on other scenes that I can
take a look at if you enjoyed this video
don't forget to click the thumbs up and
you're free to check out what the
channel has to offer in addition to the
membership options in the patreon which
I'll be linking in the description box
you can also check out my other channel
Vinnie tube Kai Vinnie tube Kai is my
second Channel and it's more focused on
video essays and Analysis videos so if
you also want to have a dose of those
especially videos on popular series and
make sure you check it out don't forget
to check out our sponsors of this video
expressvpn bypass all those pesky region
locks and even browse sites not
available in your region with the ever
trusty expressvpn now that's it for
today I hope that I can see you next
time see ya
foreign